Another way that you can consume data is
through a cross-tabulation, or Crosstab.
A Crosstab allows you to take
data within a field, and
summarize other data to the values
within that field to create a matrix.
Let's look at where we might use this.
If I have a file of schools in Wyoming,
and
I'm putting together a data
set at the zip code level,
then I'll need to summarize the schools'
data at the zip code level.
I can do simple counts
of school records or
sums of enrollment by aggregating, or
summarizing at the zip code level.
However, if I wanted to
create new fields for
each value of the level description,
or level desk field,
and sum up the number of records
in my data set, by zip code,
for each of those values,
like other, high, primary, and
so on, then I would need to create
a cross tabulation of this data.
This sort of action can be done
similarly in a pivot table in Excel.